everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
get back to doing some stuff with react
components specifically we're gonna
style some things so I know for the last
week or so we've been working with my
sequel databases and cloud storage and
setting all that up which was really
really cool learned a lot about that but
I haven't actually done any react in a
while so I'm excited to get back to it
and hey everybody see some some hellos
in the in the chat and just as I guess
an update from yesterday so decided not
to go with the basically like setting up
a cname or an a record to work with that
Google Cloud Storage so right now what
I've been doing is trying to set up the
my sequel database to work with
WordPress running on now so that's what
I was just doing just made an export of
the database from WordPress and I was
about to import it into our cloud sequel
database but I think I'm gonna put that
on hold and we're gonna do some styles
and then I'll come back to that later on
after that I'll need to set up our
WordPress URL to go to the right place
instead of our digitalocean droplet and
then we should be all good to go with
with WordPress and that'll be our
production ready WordPress deployment
some weird stuff going on outside my
office this is just checking it out all
right let me get my other screen ready
and then I'll switch over the view so
that you can see it all as well we will
mostly be in Visual Studio code
we bring this up first place will be
all right cool I think everything is set
up and should be working fine
there we are okay so this is the main
website should be pretty familiar to
everyone at at this point and I was just
finishing up a Pomodoro session so
that's how much time I have left almost
got the full session in and we're gonna
go today we're gonna look at a few
different pages and see like what what
styling needs done and we'll we'll just
kind of go from there and see what you
know what we can do so here's one thing
that my guest
yesterday noticed so we had a kind of a
guest on the show towards the end of
yesterday's show named Haley and she's
gonna help out with the site I'm hoping
to hire her on as a contract worker so
I'm gonna try to get all the details
figured out today so she can start but
she noticed here that we have you know
this this length it's just playing a
plane length right it's got the
underline it's got the blue everything
it it doesn't really like match right I
mean it has the right font at least but
it's a little weird that is just there
in this case the title actually makes
sense right it's we can tell it's a CV
right at curriculum vitae but some of
the other file names don't make any
sense so we definitely should style this
a bit differently and let people know
what it is so this is this is what we're
gonna work on first and it is going to
take a bit of CSS but we're also going
to potentially need to do some stuff
with JavaScript as well so that's first
up let me set my timer there we are
and let's get to it so this is let's
make it bigger so don't need that I was
sort of limit plan and we don't need
this right now and we don't need this
all right let me know if that flan is
big enough for everyone if you're just
joining us for the first time I just set
a Pomodoro timer and so we're gonna code
for about 25 minutes when that timer
goes off I'm going to go back to the
live chat and I'm going to answer your
questions so if you do have any
questions please put them in the chat
now and I will get to them in about 25
minutes
alright so very simple with this
component I'm gonna just describe this
hopefully said even if you don't know
react you'll know what's going on we all
our data is stored in WordPress we're
using the WordPress AP app while we're
using graph QL to pull in the data and
we're bringing that data in and we're
basically just displaying all of it in a
div on the page up here we're changing
the data a little bit there's some
things in there that just don't work for
us right now so we're changing that data
so here we're we're changing the data I
think we need to I think we need to
change a little bit about that
curriculum vitae
let's see harsh it says it's not
readable and mobile art I'll make it
bigger
hopefully that's better and I think if I
go any bigger it's going to be a little
hard to to see it enough to actually do
anything let me show you what the
mark-up looks like and that way we can
come up with a plan on how to edit that
so I'm just going to inspect this in
chrome dev tools and it's really small
so I'm gonna make this bigger okay so we
see here the link is contained inside
this CV link element and then we just
have an a tag and we have our file and
the title there so this is going to be
add straightforward to some of the other
adjustments that we made that are
already present in the component but
this is what we need to target right the
a tag within the CV link so let's let's
try to do that so we were using regular
expressions here to find what we wanted
and then we're just replacing that I'm
not sure that that's gonna work for us
now at least not in the same way so the
problem is like I can definitely target
this and this will be the same across
all of these pieces of data for these
faculty profiles but I target this and
then I still need to I need to at least
get this this href right so I guess
a truth
all right my people out there who know a
little bit more about regular
expressions let me know what you think
of this I'm gonna tell you what I want
to do but I'm not exactly sure how to do
it so let's let's work that out so
here's what I'd like to do I'd like to
potentially find this section basically
CV link a href equals and then this
first quotation mark and then grab
everything up until that second
quotation mark I want to grab that and
then insert it into a template literal
and then put that inside the CV link so
I think that'll be the best way then
what I'll do is just change the title of
this to curriculum vitae something like
that and so everybody will have a link
that just says curriculum vitae so it'll
all be standard will style the link to
so they know like there won't be a
million different you know names for
each professors curriculum vitae so no
matter what the file name is that they
upload it'll say the same thing but I do
still need to know what this with this
href is pointing to so
let's see I'm gonna see what you all are
saying about this right now michael says
can't you do CB link first child John
says find CV link and change it to html5
details element will probably be the
only of this type and style the tag a
tag under details I'm not necessarily
worried about the styling because that's
going to be I can just style the the CV
link directly would I basically I need
somehow to grab this value inside the
href if I can get this whoops if I can
get this value then I'm fine but I just
need a way to get this value only this
value in it the only information that
I'll have across all the pieces of
content that we'll have for faculty
profiles is this CV link so I need to
grab the HR value inside the a inside
the CV link if this was back in my
jQuery days this would be easy but it's
not
and essentially remember we're not
dealing with like the Dom here at this
point this is just a string coming
through so we're still dealing with this
content as a string right it gets set as
you know HTML here but we can't use like
normal at least if we're going to make
the change before it actually hits the
page we can't actually I just had an
idea
okay so
we can't I really hate to do this
because it's react but alright here's an
alternate plan what if we just let the
data go to into the Dom as is then
afterwards so like I don't know after
the components mounts or whatever then
we do some stuff to manipulate it while
it's in the Dom would that be easier
could we just go in at that point find
the a SAG within the CV link element and
then just change the text and would that
mess up
reiax ability to track what's going on
would that also mess up our server-side
rendering would the server-side
rendering be off from what's on the
client-side okay so our should say and
that would work Nikki's saying you just
want to do it in component did him out
okay
all right well let's we can try it I
think for me at least because I'm not an
expert at all in regular expressions I
think it might be easier to try the
second way but I'm still open to the
first way all right so let's let's see
let's assume I guess we can we can do
some work here in the console actually
so let's go in here the console is clear
all this out it's a document elements a
tag name and then let's say see the is a
CV link is that what it was
let's see if we can grab it yep so we
have CV link we can get that if you have
our CV link and we have our inner HTML
in our inner text yes all right how
about this the shudders
you know text equals no it didn't it
didn't actually change it shoot I need
to get more space here let's let's open
this up
all right so I can change it here but it
doesn't actually update in the dawn see
okay harsh it says
it won't mess up as that part is not
frequently re-rendered okay all right
cool awesome Michael I think your ear I
think you get the right idea that CV
link let's try this
oops what was I thinking why don't I do
this yeah yes okay that's what we need
all right cool but it's not it actually
changed everything in there okay so this
is not exactly what we want let's see
let's look at this structure a little
bit more text content I think that's
what might work better out of HTML out
of it
and it says hmm it looks like there's a
lot that we we kid tried it's argued
here let's try something else then let's
refresh the page and try something else
so it looks like we can we could try
text content or we could try outer text
I'd rather not have to mess with the a
tag at all right so let's refresh so
want to get the original the original
stuff back here we'll inspect this again
and then all right so let's check it out
instead of inner text what was I I say
we were gonna do it was a text content
okay let's see if this works it equals
it still takes a lot okay we'll have to
get hard saying use query selector
Michael's saying could we try CV links
here yeah let's let's try that so let's
say see what we get if we put a zero in
here
undefined okay you know all right so
Harshit that's a great idea so hard
saying we could do document dot query
selector and then do CV link a shoot
it's not working oh no wonder it's not
working I just took it out of the page
all right now let's try one more time CV
link a yes
okay so we have CV like a and let's try
to go what was it inner text let's try
to change that inner text yes and does
this work it does we're getting the
right nice alright so that's what we
need to use so let's copy that
and let's go over here and let's add a
component it mounts and let's try to do
is like a query selector equals you see
me we'll save you CV
[Music]
see if that works
we'll save it so this is let this be a
lesson to everyone my my mistake so when
you don't take the time to learn how to
select things in Dom with vanilla
JavaScript plain JavaScript and you just
rely on jQuery all the time you don't
remember all of these selectors so you
all were giving me the names right
luckily I also had dev tools that was
Auto completing stuff for me so I could
see what it was but if we were working
with jQuery I would know automatically
how to do that and I would have done it
in you know a minute it would've been
easy right so that's awesome if I always
get to work with jQuery but I don't
in fact I rarely use jQuery at all
anymore and I know how to do a lot with
react but when it comes to stuff like
this I don't have that background
knowledge of of it
I assume it's possible but I always have
to look it up so it slows me down so I
appreciate all the help there but
starting out sometimes you for me at
least I I know like I would look at
stuff like this and say it's so much
easier to do a jQuery I'm just gonna use
jQuery right and I never took the time
to learn that
so there's value in taking the time to
learn that like this is always going to
work but the jQuery will only work if
you're using jQuery right and you
there's not really a guarantee that
you're always going to have that of
so just just a note if you're thinking
like I did that this is just way too
much typing to do something that you
don't have to type as much to jQuery
there's definitely a time for this
alright so I know enough about that
let's see if it actually works
refresh okay re it does work there's a
little flash which is not is not
unexpected there's a small flash of the
original content so I'll say this at
this point essentially we've done what
we wanted to do with that I don't like
that there's a little flash it's not the
end of the world but that's where I
think that the regular expression
solution that I talked about first would
probably be the better solution because
we would never get that flash of content
so I guess what I'm gonna do and I'm
gonna do this right now and that way for
those of you who aren't quite familiar
with git and get up this might be
helpful to you we will go to see that
yeah we're gonna go here and I'm gonna
open up an issue right and that way this
will be good for two reasons one I won't
forget about it but then also this is
going to be there for anyone that would
like to tackle this issue and will say
this
jeez
all right so we're just gonna leave a
little a little issue right so if
anybody wants to try to tackle it and
they're good with regular expressions
they can try to you know fix that I
shouldn't say fix it
but fix it in what I think will be a
better way right they'll solve that
problem in a better way so
all right so right now and the faculty
j/s components this is probably hard to
see as a man so right now in the faculty
jazz component this text is changed
components it mouths
there we go so that's just a really
basic amount of info it does say what
what component to look in so I think
this would be OK for now potentially I
could add some screenshots and things
like that
I'm not since I'm streaming right now
but I mean the more information you can
add to an issue the more it would help
someone who wants to actually solve that
issue and we can give it a label as well
and we can say help wants it and now
everyone will know hey like this is up
for grabs
let's submit this issue okay and you
know maybe someone's interested maybe
someone's not let me check my time and
before we go on all right about two
minutes this is enough time to do some
basic CSS stuff just to see like what
we'd want to do so when we're doing CSS
I think it's always a great idea to do
your initial stuff in the end F tools so
let me get rid of my console area here
and I'm gonna push this out so we have
as much space as we can because really
what I want to get to is is this portion
here so on this a tag that's what we're
gonna focus our Styles so what we want
to do is get rid of that line so we're
gonna do text-decoration:none okay right
and that just got rid of that line for
us and I definitely want the color to be
something different so we're gonna
change that color and I I want it to be
the same color that we've been using for
links elsewhere
and let me let me find where we have
that color and do we not have it
anywhere in this place I thought we'd
have it somewhere all right let me open
up a new a new little window here so I
can find where that color is since I
can't remember what the the hex code is
pretty sure that we have it here oh
there it was I skipped over it so this
is the color we've been using for links
let's inspect grab the hex code there we
go I knew we were using something that
would be difficult to remember so we did
change it up a little bit use the hsla
instead of just a normal hex color color
there we go so that's much cleaner I
think to just have it there because it's
a different color you know it may invite
users to click if we wanted it to stand
out more if we thought maybe that was
really like important we could make
maybe the font weight a bit bigger we
could even think about making it a
button but I mean the words view CV
seemed to invite a click right
so in general I is for something like
this this is not really an action that I
want users to take I'd rather make it
subtle but clear if I really really
wanted users to click on that CV I would
probably make it a button and I would
make it stand out so that as soon as you
see that page like you that button is
right there
so I think this will be okay my timer
did just go up so I'm going to take a
short break we do a five minute break
and then we'll come back and we'll
transfer those Styles over into probably
a CSS file
for this particular component and I'll
explain why we're going to do it like
that when we when we come back for our
second Pomodoro session so right now I'm
going to scroll up to the top of the
chat try to answer as many questions as
I can in this five-minute period I'm
also going to very quickly look at my
messages and make sure that there's
nothing work-related all right it
doesn't look like it I did I just got a
charge from Google services for four
dollars and 23 cents
I wonder if that was from yesterday when
when I did all that stuff I don't know
for sure if it's from from yesterday but
it's possibly a light in space says
greetings from Germany hey how's it
going
Oh a zekiel says free code camp has been
updated and its new oh I didn't let's
check that out free code camp dot org I
have not seen the new stuff sign-in wait
really didn't you used to be able to do
this with github if you create sign-in
you're gonna click here to add an email
address to your account sign ok yep yep
yep submit yay go to the coding
curriculum yeah let's learn about that
Wow alright sorry I'm hijacking this
this five-minute session here but I
think this is amazing okay so new stuff
on free code camp a thousand coding
challenges more than a thousand new
coding challenges amazing that's really
I I might have started doing coding
challenges again I mean just for fun
just to check it out so uh the
information security stuff testing
really cool new certifications so these
are in addition to the old ones we have
there six new certifications Wow
okay so you can skip the coding
challenges and just do the project if
you're able to complete the project that
you can get the certification that's
cool alright cool they're test Suites
for the projects very cool coding
interview prep challenges that that
could be very useful very cool enhanced
privacy I'm not that worried about the
privacy
just assume I have no privacy on the
internet but if you're worried about
that that's cool
fully customizable portfolio pages
that's cool oh that's really cool so the
free code camp portfolio pages were kind
of you really couldn't do much with them
before note the platform another for
Athena learned free code camp org very
cool all right let's check that up as
you type search very cool if you've
watched what we've done with search
before you know I'm a fan of the as you
type search password the sign-in you
y'all know I'm also a big fan of the
password the sign-in as well that's cool
new welcome dashboard awesome really
cool yeah for sure let's give that a
what this is a separate account from the
throw things it over your town I know I
know
I'm pretty sure I already have this
account too right I do yes awesome
all right cool
alright so here's the new some of the
curriculum the new stuff I'm not gonna
go through all of it but just to see
like what we have here cool
got some react stuff Redux dative is AP
is security and the coding prep stuff
really cool new stuff like CSS grid
that's cool that this is really cool
what is this introduction go to the
first lesson really cool
that's awesome
Wow there are a lot of coding project
all right challenges you can see I
haven't got any of my certificates yet
zero out of six but anyway that's that's
cool hopefully that that was helpful for
you all I was just really excited so you
know what let me let me needs to reset
that and answer some questions since I
said I was going to do five minutes of
questions
who aim high seer yeah I I haven't seen
you here in a long time I was it going
how's the the job going you don't have
to tell me on the chat if you don't want
to but send me a DM or something and let
me know I'm interested to see how it's
to know what's you know what's going on
with that Dutchess is here good morning
thanks for watching
harsh it only has two days left for the
summer holidays so will you have you
have a lot less time then after the
holidays harsh it
and Ezekiel says this is the best day
ever in my life
is that because the new freakout cam
stuff came out lucifer says hi hey how's
it going
[Music]
Luke kesh says can anyone explain how to
set up a basic react app with an express
server project without something like
create react app or gas fee I want to do
that on cloud base I des like glitch is
intended the truth dive I don't know
that I've ever setup react without using
something like next or create react app
I think I use Gatsby once so yeah I
don't I'm not the person to talk to
about that just because I always I never
really had a use case where it would be
valuable for me to do it like that but
I'm I'm sure you know probably some of
the other people with a chat have done
it like that I like to asked if the this
method that we ended up going with is
more reliable than the regular
expression I don't know about reliable
to be honest with you I would think the
method that we used is probably less
reliable I mean they're they're both
it's probably gonna work but the fact
that there's a delay between like the
Dom loads the user actually sees this I
don't know that makes me a little bit
nervous so I think for this use case
either one would work but I would
definitely feel more comfortable with a
regular expression way of doing it but
sometimes it's just like you make it
work and then if you have time like you
can go back and do it but on a project
this big it just doesn't make sense for
me to spend a ton of time on small
details like this at least not before
launch like after launch I couldn't go
like work out all these details but if I
try to do all the details now like the
site won't launch for you know months
and months Michael says I didn't realize
you could use multiple tags in query
selector I usually cascade them I didn't
realize you could either but that's
really really helpful I'm going to take
a drink before we start our next session
okay I didn't get through everything in
the chat so I will have to pick up where
I left off and when we come back
but now let's do some CSS and where's my
timer there we go let's set this we'll
probably just do one more Pomodoro
session and then I got to get back to
spending the rest I have so much to do
today actually if you excuse me for a
second let me just vent for a second on
air so I'm giving a talk this weekend at
Pittsburg tech fest on basically setting
up what we've been doing here for the
last few months
react with WordPress as the content
management system using graph QL I
wanted to do videos so that I could set
tell people at my talk like if you want
to know more in depth check out the
videos because I think I only have a
half an hour so obviously I'm not gonna
go step-by-step through this whole thing
I didn't haven't made the videos yet
like well obviously we've done it on the
live stream but I'm not gonna tell
people like hey go watch on a 100 plus
hours of the live stream just for this
project so I need to work on that I have
a little bit of work to do for client
like realistically it'll probably take
me 15 minutes to do the client work but
it's still like it's something else on
my mind that has to be done by tomorrow
at in tomorrow morning and then I sell
both this work right for this site so
there's still data that needs to be
brought over both to the database and to
the google cloud storage bucket so a lot
I haven't done any work out today which
may not seem like a big deal to you but
for like mental health purposes if I
don't get workouts in for a few days in
a row like I will definitely feel
depressed so while I'm still feeling
upbeat I need to get that workout in if
I wait til tomorrow
I'm afraid like I will just not be up
for it
and it'll probably be a downward spiral
for a few days so alright then over just
wanted to share that with you all let's
get back to this all right so I like
this let's take this now which why did I
do that let's grab this and I'm going to
copy this not really that much to type
out but I'm not gonna remember that to
type it out and let's go over here and
see first of all do we have styles yes
we do we have a faculty CSS file that we
can use and that's awesome so let's put
it in there and as we're putting that in
there I'm gonna explain why we're using
this instead of styles inside of our
component which we've done on some other
components so in within our project we
have a static folder and styles and then
there that's where all our CSS files are
okay so let's go down yeah I'm just
gonna put this down here
and we'll go see the link a and then
we'll paste those in save it and let's
refresh and make sure that it'll work
yep there we go our styles are there and
we can verify here yep the styles are
there it's coming from our faculty CSS
file great here's what we did it like
that the the content that we're bringing
in that we want to style right we're
bringing it in from WordPress as a
string and then we're adding it to the
Dom here right so
there's no there are no elements present
within this component as it is now where
I could just put a style on there like
in line or where I could add a class to
to let's say if I did all the Styles up
here is like a JavaScript object you
know I couldn't add that as we've done
in other components right because those
essentially like those elements that are
ending up on the page don't even exist
at that point so what we end up having
to do then is kind of do it the
old-fashioned way where we put in this
this head tag here with a link to our
CSS file as we move forward and clean up
this data and pull it in as I really
want to do it you know the best way that
I know how we can phase this out and we
can start putting all our Styles inside
our component either as inline Styles or
as JavaScript object
all right then everything can be truly
like modular right and reusable we can
get rid of the CSS files for now of
posts now that we have in WordPress of
custom posts which I've shown you all
before it's just it's too much so that's
why we're doing it this way if if I
could I would do it differently but
there's not really anything wrong with
doing it like this it does just get to
be a bit of a mess we have so many
different CSS files for a different
component some components we have styles
going on in three different ways we have
inline styles in the component we have
styles in a JavaScript object in a
component and then we have styles in a
CSS file that gets pulled into the unit
so we don't have a lot of consistency in
our CSS right now but that's that's a
known issue it's it's what we have to
work out now it's kind of like an
in-between step to get this thing
running
but eventually
we will this will be in better shape you
know once we have more time but right
now a lot of people are expecting this
site to launch so in terms of what the
user will see they'll never know the
difference when we switch all this over
it'll be the same for them so it's only
going to be from the standpoint of
developers and how easy it is to figure
out what's going on and and you know
contribute edit the files that'll be a
lot nicer once everything is you know
organized properly and in terms of you
know all the data like how we're pulling
it in okay so let's move on you check
the time yeah let's move on we'll do a
quick scan at this page and just say
look over here I think it looks I mean
the rest of this page looks alright
there's nothing that stands out in ink
when it comes to styles there's always
more you could probably do but right now
I'm not looking for that I'm looking for
is there something that looks really
weird on this page that looks maybe
broken or something like that so from
that point of view I don't see anything
right so let's go let's see let's just
check page we'll just go down through
and check some pages just really quickly
I mean look broken actually I did see
something so let's go to device and
let's try this pixel to see what it
looks like this is not good all right so
we have this split here so I noticed
this yesterday when I was looking at
this on a phone so let's try that out we
try to fix that and see wow that's just
hanging out there right so it's we have
an h2 tag
then an image and then right below that
we just we just have the text so the
image is actually within the h2 that's a
little odd you usually don't see that
but that's what we have to work with
right now so ideally what we want to do
is if we can keep the markup exactly the
same and just use CSS that's ideal that
takes the least amount of time for us if
we have to adjust the markup we want to
do that within the component using
regular expressions or like we just did
you know with a bit of JavaScript
because that saves us from having to
manually edit it if both of those things
are impossible which we haven't really
come across that yet but if they were
impossible that would mean we'd have to
go back manually edit all that stuff in
a bunch of places you don't want to have
to do that so let's try the first thing
CSS let's see what we can do so we're
gonna have to put the styles on the h2
tag itself and I'm gonna make this
bigger since you know we're dealing with
this small viewport so we can make this
a lot bigger we already have our h2 here
so already putting some Styles on here
in the department dot CSS file so let's
see just wrap I'm not really sure what's
it what to do here word wrap all right
so we have break word that looks
terrible as well so I'm not I'm not
gonna go with that maybe let's put
something on this image how about that
let's see wow it has inline Styles on it
already so that's getting pulled in
float:right
let me know what your thoughts are on on
this image but here's what I'm thinking
what if we go with
left and let's do
let's take out this height 100% take out
the height
[Music]
now is this gonna I want to see how this
looks up here actually I know this
that's way too big great we don't want
don't want it that big all right how
about let's refresh the page reset it
and let's go with we on the image
you may just need to go with a media
clear here
Oh John Hanson is saying
white-space:nowrap John is he's also
saying how does that even happen image
nested in an h2 should not even render
yeah but this is the mark-up that we've
inherited so we got to work with it
at least for a little while alright so
let's try I'll get rid of that let's see
what John said white-space:nowrap
and let's go back to this maybe I need
to put that on the h2
oh not Lucas just try a fixed height
with auto width okay you try that Nicki
says doesn't make it so that CSS isn't
global and only for that page
yeah yeah so each page has its own CSS
file all right so that's not it's not
gonna work at least not like as is but
let's go down to this image and see if
we can
mmm-hmm let me see some of the other
things I mean it's resized and soon
all right
let's let's reset again and alright
let's assume to make this simpler let's
assume that we're going to use a media
query so we only have to deal with the
mobile size so let's figure out where
that query needs to be so we'll figure
out exactly where this starts looking
really weird right here so let's make
that media query at about 500 pixels
just to make it a nice even number so
that we can remember so at about 500
pixels then we're going to do this
we're gonna get rid of the float
and let's go with cities are our let's
go with eight pixels Auto actually I
don't really like that being centered
let's let's get rid of the margin and
margin Auto and let's just go with the
margin of eight pixels all around so I
like now you know what I don't even like
that let's go with the margin of eight
and zero all right that looks a lot
better like and by better I don't mean
ideal right not perfect but it doesn't
look like it's broken now alright so
basically here's what we've done and
this is only gonna apply when it's under
500 pixels right because let's just see
like this is what it would look like
when it's over not terrible but it
definitely doesn't look as good we have
all this white space right that's not
that's not better than what we had
before where you had a nice wrapping
effect so for under 500 pixels we're
going to get rid of the float we're
gonna add a margin of 8 pixels top and
bottom right because we need a little
bit of that space here up at the top
it's fine we already have some space but
I'm putting the 8 there just in case you
know if if let's say I come back in and
do different things with this facing I
don't have to worry about it being too
close so but we do want at least 8
pixels of space between here you know
potentially even more you know that
still might be a little close but we got
our mounting this is on a smaller screen
so we don't want to have a ton of space
that's going to increase the amount of
scroll and then we set it to display
block right that's what finally kind of
pushed this down
from where it was so let's put this now
in our department dot CSS file and we're
going to have to use important because
this is on the element
hopefully this alert that's on the
element alright let's see if it works
yeah so we need to be able to override
these inline Styles right that are right
there coming through like from the data
that we're pulling in alright so let's
find our toys are static static static
Department
don't see it so we are using Department
dot CSS I guess we'll just continue to
use that technically this isn't a
department page but let's let's do it
and let's go with inch this is h2 yeah I
guess I'm okay with this
it's we'll put this on the h2 image yeah
so this will only work on images that
are in an h2 tag which is fine I'm
hoping that that's a rare occurrence
so let's go h2 image forgot I'm not
using sass all right we got to do the
media query first at media and media
screen and max with this is 500 reset
500 pixels what did i do what did I mess
up
nothing right this works and whoops and
then we need to say h2 image we'll add
that in there and we also need to do
floats what we want to do float none
yeah none let's just verify that that
works yep so we're gonna do floats none
and we're gonna put important on there
we don't normally want to use important
right so in this case though we have to
because the the mark-up is really
forcing us to because I'm not going to
be able to override inline styles
without using that I'm just going to go
ahead and throw it on each one of these
it might not be necessary on everyone
but since we're already using it there's
not really that much value in messing
around and and potentially not having
ourselves work so let's see if this
works
refresh okay awesome so that works we
can see these styles are being
overridden but the real test is was this
work yep that works awesome so you can
see we don't have all that whitespace
once again probably not how I would make
this page if I was doing it from scratch
but now it won't look broken and not
only that hopefully every other page
that's using that CSS file that has an
image inside an h2 tag will now be fixed
all right cool let me check my time
three more minutes let's see if we can
find something to squeeze in here in
there's three minutes also I'd like to
see like are we having similar issues
Wow so this is going float respect
that's not a great image like I I
normally like the image of the San
Damiano crucifix like we used it in the
catechol Institute website that was
project one and it looked amazing but
with this background color it doesn't
stand out so I'm definitely gonna at
some point probably try to replace that
image but for now that's the image that
we have so this is an image within an h1
tag Wow okay and it is using Department
CSS so let's let's do the same thing
that we just did but let's also add in
h1 tags so within here let's just go
with each one image and h2 image are
gonna have the same same styling we'll
see
that will do a refresh and we'll see
okay that's on this side and then but
when it gets bigger we still have the
effect that we want all right great
I think that looks better you know not
perfect but much better than having it
flow to the right all right awesome
we've got about a minute left not really
confident I can get anything else done
in a minute but let's see new info
coming soon employment HR wonderful all
right that page actually looks like
there's no change needed faculty opening
nope and that page doesn't work I have a
list of all the pages that don't work so
I am aware of them all academics
undergraduate this page yeah this face
is actually okay we can go did we
already check these out we did some
styling work on these pages this is kind
of weird so we have different font with
our font font weights I mean they're
different font weights going on a lot of
different font weights and sizes
happening here so it could probably use
some cleanup at the very least if like
this text we're just all the same I
think that would be better but that'll
be I have to save that for a different
time this will end up being an easy fix
though but my timer is running out I am
curious to see why it's doing this mmm
okay so these have some inline styles
that are overriding what we have here so
really if we just went with you know
something like using important for the
styles that are likely already there
those P tags then I think that that
would work so for instance we could just
important here and this should override
it right so now we have the proper line
height and then I'm not sure where yeah
so the font should be Roboto font family
but that's all the way on main so we're
bought a saying say San serif should be
important to interesting but that's not
hmm yeah so we may have to go ahead on
the P tags and put in font family Roboto
important right that would fix it see so
not not really a difficult fix here so
and this is a major CSS but like really
this is something that could probably be
used like across the board this is
standard for P tags so they may want to
make some sort of global style so we
don't repeat it all over the place
I kind of think that font is a little
small - I mean it's 18 pixels but maybe
it's just my screen okay now I'm gonna
go back to the live chat and answer as
much as I can also let's let's go ahead
and push these changes to github get
status so we can see we've changed
faculty a Dodge is our department dot
CSS and faculty dot CSS so let's do a
git add and yarn CM let's do a feature
and let's just say styles for CV link
and images and header tags heading
okay that works no breaking changes it
does not affect open issues it's going
to run all the linting all the Auto
formatting all the tests and then it
will commit after that assuming
everything passes all right so while
that's doing its thing I will answer
some questions and then I'll make sure
that I push this up to github so that
you all can check this out if you want
oh that was fast
awesome so now I just do get push and
everything is now available on github
well now it is
I'm just trying to find where I left off
okay let's see now
I should ask can anyone help make an
awesome card component for the UI
library that I am working on alright so
let her should know how I should I would
love to help you make a card component
but I don't think I'll have time for
sure not this week or weekend so I guess
it depends on how soon you want it done
but if I can I'll try to help
John says have you not been using
therefore your CSS colors no I haven't I
haven't I really I should I should use
CSS variables
Nietzsche says did the new curriculum
finally launch nice yeah it looks like
it
John says it can be helpful if the link
text that isn't an obvious link to load
with a subtle but obvious animation like
color scale translator transform when
the element comes as well yet now I
don't have it up there yeah you're right
you know maybe it might not be a bad
idea for all links to I don't know if
this is exactly what you're talking
about but now that you said that it kind
of makes me think you know potentially
maybe there should be some sort of
animation on hover for a link other than
just the cursor you know the typical
course or pointer I would want it to be
subtle something just like a very slight
shift in in color maybe just in the
maybe a little lighter or a little
darker nothing nothing too crazy
that Duchess is this is really in
comment to someone else in the chat Matt
duchesses only game minecraft once in a
while I just stood out to me cuz I
really like Minecraft I got my my oldest
son into it actually
all my kids except for the baby or into
Minecraft its they love it even like my
three-year-old wants to play Minecraft
he gets him so stuck in in like holes
and needs help to get out but he likes
to run around and and like dig get
skeletons and stuff but anyway I don't
know anybody else a Minecraft fan out
there like you can you spend a lot of
time in Minecraft and just get lost in
that that world but uh I think it's a
fun game
Aniki says new livestream idea Jesse
gets free code camp certifications
actually that would be fun
that would be really so if it ever
happens that I can't livestream my
actual work projects like I don't know
if it happens he it probably won't
happen here but like let's say I have to
get it done another job for whatever
reason and I can't then maybe that would
be a great idea for a stream to do like
all the free code camp projects live
that would be fun although like I
already have so many side project ideas
to do as well so I could definitely work
on those too
Nicola ass is this website only
front-end no so we're doing everything
for it for this particular stream today
we were just working with front-end
stuff but in previous streams and in
future streams you know we were working
with back-end which is node but we also
have WordPress setup and we build PHP
plugin for that and got cloud sequel
database cloud storage like we're
working on a lot of a lot of stuff so
kind of a larger project and so I think
there's there's something for everyone
in this process a
Nietzsche says is there a reason that
you import that stylesheet and the head
tag instead of just importing the CSS
file is that an XJS thing or is it
server-side rendering thing to be honest
with you I don't remember why we did it
that way
I just vaguely remember that we had to
do it that way and that I did try to do
it a different way
but I really can't recall I mean it's
probably on a stream but I don't
remember when that that happened so yeah
I really don't remember what it could be
that I could do it another way and then
I just didn't figure that way out and
this one worked so I went with it but I
can't remember
this scrub scrub I don't know how to
pronounce skru BYZ says no love for
flexbox and that was probably when we
were doing the image thing so I like
flexbox but we just were having to deal
with floats already set like we brought
this content over from an older system
and that's how how they were doing it so
we're just kind of dealing with what we
have
let's see Aniki says the what frequency
in a code review of that stuff you have
to work with would be off the charts
yeah I'm like I'm so used to it it
doesn't really surprise me that much so
when I see this but it's it is pretty
wild though I mean it keeps it fun like
surprising like it's really it's cool
like like wow I've never seen that
before I mean that's that's kind of fun
that I've been doing this for years and
years and it's like I still see stuff in
websites that I've never seen that in
terms of the markup like haven't seen
that before that's cool it's just
amazing what will actually work in a
browser you know like you can you can do
crazy stuff with a markup and it still
actually renders
michael creo says do you run lighthouse
audits on your sites i was thinking
about accessibility yeah I recently ran
an audit on on this site that we're
working on and I actually got a decent
accessibility score so that's going to
be something that we will be working on
it may be I'm not exactly sure if it'll
be pre or post launch when we do a lot
with that because realistically like
even this site as is is a huge
improvement over the the current web
site so I think it's even if we don't
have perfect accessibility score it's
still gonna be more accessible I want to
double check that to verify but I'm
pretty sure it is still be more
accessible so I think as an incremental
step launching this would be good and
then we can try to work towards being
like fully accessible so but it is
coming it's something that is definitely
on my mind and I think it's important so
that I not I hope hopefully would love
to do work on that during a stream go
through the whole process - of using
lighthouse I don't know if everybody
knows what it is or how to use it but it
might be cool to do a whole stream just
on going lighthouse and trying to fix
all the stuff that can get our scores up
thanks for bringing that up
Jeff says I have a minecraft server
running at home cool
med that just says cool I fall off in
love a lot
then log like I hate that I mean you get
your character they all build up and you
have the sweet armor and stuff and like
no enemies can take you out and then you
just mess up and fall in love at once
and you're done anyway
oh cool you know what I've never tried
to do anything with servers like playing
online with servers on minecraft I
always because my kids are playing it I
was like I'm just gonna let you play
this offline and it'll be safe but maybe
like if I'm supervising I could get try
that out because that's a whole like
part of the game that seems really cool
that I've never experienced without my
minecraft by the way
Zuber says hi i disconnected from your
Shing for a while is this still
university project any plans for
starting a new project from beginning
then oh yeah we definitely will this is
so the university project we for sure
have have new projects coming up so it
will start one from beginning to end
here I can't tell you for sure when that
will happen but it will definitely
happen I'm sure my bosses have lots of
stuff lined up for me after I launched
this site
mate it may seek says can you show what
you did already create the website yeah
you know what let me let me show you
this site but then also so this I'll
just show you the home page there's
likes way too much to show the whole
site but I can give you the link as well
so I'm gonna type that into the live
chat here now okay so I just put the
link in the live chat if anybody would
like to go to the site check it out
you'll feel free let me know if you've
got any ideas for making it better or if
you if you see something that's like for
sure broken please let me know anyway
but you know just kind of really briefly
here's the home page you know one thing
I was thinking about for accessibility
is I don't really know if this text is
readable enough like for a person with
like good vision it's okay but if
somebody doesn't have great vision I'm
not really sure like I I'm thinking
about maybe doing something I mean I
like this image and yeah I don't know
what I'm gonna do about that but that's
something I'm not I've been thinking
about lately you know about maybe doing
something with it
John Hanson says mistakes in HDL markup
get rendered in the Dom only because the
dome sees the mistakes and bandages them
on the fly not like PHP that's cool I
mean it's I know it's good and bad right
it could it can encourage people to
write their markup in ways that aren't
the best you can write markup in ways
that are let's say entirely unaccessible
to screen readers and things like that
and it'll still work and so unless
people get away with that but at the
same time it makes it really easy to
build websites even if they're not great
websites you can so I don't know I guess
their pros and cons to that duchesses
yeah I wanted to see accessibility and
lighthouse I heard of it but haven't
used it yeah it's really cool I'll
definitely I'll try to do stream on that
soon then this is I yeah it's it's
awesome so I definitely want to kind of
show it to you all
Anna says hi it's my first time here and
I don't understand why we left image in
h1 and h2 is it because you're working
on an old project and you are afraid
that initial styling would crash well
kind of right so it is an old project
but what we did is we brought over all
this markup from one database and
transferred it to a new one so that same
pattern of image tags being used inside
heading tags is used in a lot of places
most likely so trying to find all those
places and change the markup in every
place would be really difficult it would
time-consuming so that's why we're just
trying to work with it as is I do have a
plan to go through and change those
eventually but right now I just need to
get it looking good on a screen so that
we can launch it and then hopefully I
can have some student workers interns
contract workers go through all that
data and clean it up so that we don't
have weird stuff like that going on but
that's definitely a legit question you
normally would not want to leave the
image in the h1 tag although like it
renders not really the best markup right
but anyway good good question and also
let me know if it's an ax or onna or I
don't want to mispronounce your name so
let me know what you prefer Chris says
how is CSS grid coming along for me
personally I haven't really been able to
do much with it I haven't had time to to
work with it
Aniki says you can outrun a lighthouse
check on a page directly from the chrome
dev tools it's inside the audits head
yeah yeah it's it's awesome it's so easy
to run it
Oh Jeff says this is for Minecraft again
but this stream has gotten hijacked by
minecraft so Jeff says you can set up a
server using docker and then let them
connect to it locally that's your genius
you are a minecraft genius that's an
awesome idea I'm gonna have to check
that out like I literally have like old
pcs just sitting around not doing
anything I could like have a server
running locally with docker like all the
time and that's that's cool I love that
idea thank you
that doesn't says it's good you monitor
your kids on there I played on servers
with some creepers so I play on a
kid-friendly one okay cool that's good
to know that I'm not just being paranoid
I like I just assume anything that's
multiplayer online it potentially
there's a way for inappropriate stuff to
be done or said or whatever on there so
that's why I just never let let my kids
try that so so I guess that is that is
in fact the case unfortunately Michael
Chris has set up a Raspberry Pi as as a
sir that would be cool that'd be really
cool
Ezekiel says they have a question sure
what's your question I'm not sure so
Ezekiel you never put your questions so
let me know what it is if I in the
stream before you can give me the
question Senate DME on Twitter or on
some social media site and I'll answer
it and that - just said site is looking
good thank you thank you I appreciate it
Chris says I have 2050 and 2070 vision
and the text looks fine to me however I
am on a 32 inch TV ok cool out you know
maybe I'll just we'll see maybe I'm
worrying about it like prematurely you
know I haven't gotten any like
complaints about it so yeah maybe it's
not it's not about Jeff says I can see
if I can find a docker file for you yeah
that would be awesome yeah if you could
that would I would really appreciate
that
primal fear says keep up the good work
thank you I appreciate that Phoenix says
I love the grid and I have a slight
crush on flesh that's awesome I love
that the way you expressed that oh cool
this is John and Nikki both are saying
that great and flexbox can be used
together that's really cool all right
I've gotten to the bottom of the live
chat and wow the stream is pretty
decently long we're over an hour and a
half now so I'm really really hungry I'd
love to get some lunch right now and I
don't know this was a fun stream let me
know if you like these streams where we
kind of do some more like basic CSS
stuff it's definitely fun for me
because usually everything I try works
eventually and so anyway I had a good
time with some art tomorrow's Friday
I'll do my best to stream tomorrow
although like as I said I have a lot to
do before my talk on Saturday if anybody
is in Pittsburgh and I don't know if
they're still selling tickets to
Pittsburgh tech fest but if they are
check it out come see me and if you're
gonna be there like find me and
introduce yourself I'd love to meet meet
you all in person so maybe I stream
tomorrow maybe not if I don't sing
tomorrow then and probably won't see you
until Monday but until next time have a
wonderful day and work weekend